we're sign up before mr. castles
ancestor the Reverend
one of the original founders / Gayle and
I return promoters what showing the
moral foundations of society and the
title pressing issues this year is
lectures will be delivered by David
nation who is James Watkins before and
these Watkins
David is an eminence floral arrow' from
very politics he has conducted research
on political culture ethnic conflict and
civil war and has filled it for these
the ranges from countries like Somalia
and Nigeria the France epigonion is
Claudia he has published seven books and
I counted more than 120 articles in
these professional distinctions are too
many to mention he's basically done
everything there's
well it's a great honor to be in this
place not all of you know but this is in
this University George Murdoch did
foundational work in Africa and
ethnography David Apter did the first
political science work on African and
the new states of Africa and his work on
Gold Coast and Ghana billfolds did the
first work in understanding
nation-building his student geoff hurst
you'll be hearing a lot about his work
in a subsequent lecture was a student of
falses here at yale linen wine Chacon
taught here in political science wasn't
a big influence on the lecturers coming
up and I don't know if Chris Rodriguez
here because I don't know Christopher
jury
but his work he should be standing here
rather than die so this is a very very
distinguished place for for work in
Africa and I feel honored to be
lecturing about Africa at Yale lecture 1
of this lecture series will be called is
called the unfulfilled dreams of African
independence here I take you from the
initial hopes of the independence years
to some quantitative data about
performance in the first half century of
African independence in the second
lecture the half century of
dysfunctional politics is in the sense
described without so much the
quantitative work but actually how it
looks on the ground and the third
lecture on Monday is the lecture that
brings together research of the last 15
years by some of the top scholars in
America to try to find out what are the
causes of this dysfunction and the
causal theories that try to explain why
Africa is in the last frontier have have
great resonance and help understand
where remedies might lie I should say
before starting this lecture that it's
pretty depressing the day that I'm going
to show you but I want to say that as of
the last 48 hours in the most
challenging scale for attaining
democracy Nigeria has met that scale as
of yesterday and it's something with
relatively low degrees of violence and
so it's something that we could say as a
counterweight to the quantitative
material I will be presenting in the
next hour so let me start with the dream
the dream is more personal to me I think
then to Africa itself but when John
Kennedy was elected senator his first
speech in I'm talking about four Impala
was a speech in which he put his name
behind support of African independence
and the Algerian rebels against French
imperialism the most powerful single
force he argued I can't read it on my
own screen in the world today is neither
communism nor capitalism neither the
h-bomb nor the guided missile it's a man
it's man's internal desire to be free
and independent if we have to secure the
friendship of the Arab the African and
the Asian and we must despite what John
Foster dollar says about not being a
popularity context contest we cannot
hope to accomplish it solely by means of
billion dollar foreign aid programs we
cannot win their hearts by making them
dependent upon our handouts nor can we
keep them free by selling them free
enterprise by describing the perils of
communism or the prosperity of the US or
limiting our dealings to military pacts
no the strength of our appeal to these
key populations and it's rightfully our
appeal and not that of the Communists
lies in our traditional and deeply felt
philosophy of freedom and independence
for all peoples everywhere giving
support against the French for the
National Liberation Front of Algeria
that's the dream I call Africa as the
new frontier and it had as well
described by David Apter who taught here
with its charismatic moment when Kwame
Nkrumah in the Legislative Assembly of
of Gold Coast soon to be Ghana we prefer
he said self-government with danger to
servitude in tranquillity and while we
are making our claim for self-government
I want to emphasize mr. speaker that
self-government is not an end in itself
is a means to an end to the building of
the good life for the benefit of all
this was the dream of the new frontier
with its charismatic moment in the late
1950s and early 1960s it's certainly
that optimism was infectious it led me
and my first trip abroad really to that
beautiful place of Mogadishu Somalia
where I began as a Peace Corps volunteer
and I have to say
that that experience has many ways
guided my whole professional career just
a love for the place and a sense of deep
disappointment and distress watching
what's happened in the past half century
it's that love for the place and yet
connected to a sense of how could it go
so wrong
that drives so much of my work after
finishing my dissertation and first book
on Somalia I moved to the other side of
the continent to research project in
Nigeria where I asked the question what
about the remarkable persistence even in
the era of Boko Haram of religious
toleration among Yerba Christians and
Muslims I couldn't figure out why Yerba
Muslims and Christians were so tolerant
of one another and I wrote a book to see
if I could figure it out
but from that's a picture of me I'm not
that recognizable I see but from the oh
gee oh by the king's market there in la
FA I learned the onion principle from
this merchant which has also guided my
research my next-door neighbor in la FA
was an art historian named Roland abbe
Oldham and Roland took me to the ojio by
the first time and we bought onions from
this merchant and he bargained for about
15 minutes for one kilo of of onions
I watched the bargaining very very
carefully and after a considerable
amount of time in a bargaining style I
didn't really understand but learned
from him he got her down to four naira
per the key for the kilo which was all
right I thought next week
Roland couldn't make it so I went by
myself and passing her stall she said
customer customer pointing to me I'll
give it to you right away for naira for
you for your onions no need to bargain
that's great I thought quickly but my
onions I was going to get out of that
market in less than an hour and a half
got back to my home knocked on Roland's
door and said
hi this is easy in Nigeria I got the
onions for four naira without even any
bargaining he said David onions at the
market price this week is one naira 50
Cobo I've told students over the years
not to write about any country in which
they cannot buy onions at the market
price so crossing what frontier three
outcomes will guide the lecture series
first achieving health and economic
prosperity second achieving social order
and security and third achieving
democracy those are the outcome
variables in which I'm going to compare
Africa's performance to other countries
that achieved independence more or less
at the same time and my hope in this
first lecture and then providing
data-driven analysis of Africa's
condition in regard to these outcomes
that I do not radically violate my onion
principle outcome number one economic
development and health this is from the
research of one of my PhD students
working on health in Uganda and looking
at the president's emergency fund for
revocation of of AIDS and the maternity
ward in Kampala both in from Uganda
health sector and this sort of is a
metaphor that front left tire I think is
a metaphor for great programs going awry
let's look at some of the data in terms
of per capita income with Africa with
Africa in this color we see that
compared to the other countries of of
the world Africa's development has
gone nowhere in the last half-century
it's stayed stagnant and this is per
capita GDP where you see Oceana
you see Asia and the Americas advancing
over this period Africa has stayed zags
stagnant why is this the case why should
it be the case in matter of fact when
you read standard neoclassical economic
theory of the 1960s this could not have
been predicted because there were the
ideas of neoclassical theory that there
would be technological diffusion that
capital would come into Africa because
labor would be cheap eventually there'll
be convergence and all neoclassical
theory was predicting convergence here
we see separation if we look at selected
societies what's often mentioned and
beginning of African politics courses is
that Republic of Korea and Kenya had the
same GDP per capita independence in 1963
and if you read the literature that I
was taught from the 1960s all the
reasons that are given for Africa's
failures were attributed to the South
Korea didn't have entrepreneurial spirit
that there was high levels of corruption
there was dictatorship all the things
that are now said to seeking to explain
Africa were there for Kenya were there
sorry for for Korea and yet Korea had a
gigantic economic takeoff while Africa
stayed stagnant and you see that for
China and Korea as opposed to Angola
Nigeria and Kenya in terms of economic
growth each line is a particular country
and you'll see spurts apart you'll see
in this graph from 1960 spurts of growth
average spurts of growth and some
stagnant but average spurts of growth in
all continents except for Africa and so
it hasn't had and I'll get to this in
second lecture more but even the 20
countries now which is some of the
fastest-growing countries in the world
in Africa today that still the growth
rates per capita are around two and a
half percent growth rates without per
capita are about four and a half percent
it's still even when you get to the to
the fast growing countries it still
doesn't have that Tiger aspect that
other continents have had which have
brought engines of growth for long-term
economic prosperity let's look at data
on poverty this box graph basically
choose takes the median for every
continent the median by country and this
is the 25th and 75th percentiles in the
distribution of cases of poverty of
people percentage of people living on
less than us $2 a day and we see Africa
just the median is we're talking about
72% of the population living on less
than $2 a day you can't you can't have a
love and appreciation for Africa without
asking yourself how could this be and
what could be done all the other
continents of the world the poverty
rates are nowhere as de-stressing clean
water access how many people the
percentage of people based on surveys
who have access to clean water and we
see again Africa as an outlier with the
median somewhere about 65% of the
population only 65% of the population
having access to the potable water
education this is a remarkable graph put
together by one of our graduate students
Agustina peg Leon based upon data mostly
from alt Enoch and some from the Barrow
Lee data set and which this does it
looks at two dimensions the average
years of schooling for the population
ages 15 to 19 averaged over 1970 to 2010
so that so here we see on average of
four and a half years of schooling for
Africa as opposed to say average of nine
years in Western Europe this axis is a
remarkable remarkable achievement a
dimension developed by Al Tanaka and his
colleagues and what they do is they look
at exams in math and language for for a
large number of countries and there are
all sorts of regional tests which are
sort of alike so is a bunch of African
countries that use what's called sac MEC
southern and East African sourcing from
monitoring educational quality and then
there is another test called the quality
of student achievement index which is
given in only some countries and what
they do
LT NOK and others is use the the
International exam as a bridge to be
able to to see how to code these
regional ones based upon that the
relationship to the international exams
so this is in the sense how well
students perform and this is on a scale
think of this as if you add a zero these
are like College Board's going from 200
to 800 and so here it's 50 to 20 to 20
to 80 and the standard deviation is 10
and and the the mean is here is 50 and
50 and we see again sub-saharan Africa
having the lowest years of schooling per
capita
and for those who actually are schooled
controlling for grade the lowest
achievement the human capital production
of human capital therefore in Africa is
on two dimensions at the very bottom
corner of of this districts of this
distribution
infant mortality those of those of
people in the international health
sector are pointing yes to this drop
here in Africa over the last 15 years
but I think it shows again the
tremendous gap in infant mortality of
Africa compared to the rest of the
continents in the world
infant mortality in selected cases here
again we look at China and Republic of
Korea which have brought themselves down
basically to Western European standards
and then we look at Kenya and Nigeria
which are still way above the
international standards in infant
mortality maternal mortality the same
number of women this is World
Development Index of women by per 10,000
some some wata scaled who died in
childbirth not aids-related it's an
extraordinary loss of life in the
process of giving birth that is
unimaginable for people living in other
continents tremendously depressing but
something that has to be faced up to
that Africa's advance although in terms
of percentage significant and the people
in the health sector and the people in
USAID and and Gates Foundation and
others are basically saying pointing to
this as gains and I think that's good to
be talked about the percentage of gains
but still the difference from the life
chances of people and other contents of
the world is a great gap that has to be
recognized before we could actually
think about solutions or actually think
about causes maternal mortality in
selected cases more or less we're seeing
the same picture whereas China and and
Republic of Korea have basically gone to
Western European standards remember they
started off more or less as Kenya did
and GD we work at a time of independence
so we're not talking about a different
starting place
but we're talking about quite a big
difference in how they ended so much for
health and health and economic
development we move now to the second
outcome social order and security
Freetown is an amazing has an amazing
history
it's called Freetown as many of you know
because the British slave blockade
brought the captured ships brought the
captured ships to Sierra Leone and
missionaries basically housed and
educated a whole generation of Africans
from all over West Africa and many of
them returned to their homelands
especially in Nigeria Europe is from
Nigeria and became the early nationalist
leaders so it has a very distinct very
distinguished and interesting history
but it fell as did Liberia as to either
chaos in the late 1990s and break down
where where soldiers in the streets were
basically stealing and and feeling and
killing in norther to enrich themselves
or to enrich their militias it became a
place that was unimaginable to live in a
breakdown of social order so if you look
at what one indicator is the percentage
of countries in the given year they're
considered by polity to be in the
condition of complete collapse of
central authority and this is the state
failure as a percentage of countries in
the continent and we see about 8 percent
of the countries in Africa our state
failures unable to provide basic order
at for several years and this has been
going down in the past several years and
we will be talking about that some but
in terms of the breakdown of the the the
basic breakdown of order Africa has had
too many cases with unimaginable
consequences for their populations and I
at being a Somalia staffer stay feel it
most strongly trying people trying to to
live a normal life
in fqa or Mogadishu Orcas Mayo in in
Somalia for an average state failed
fairly index states are ranked from 0 to
10 with 0 being the most stable
that's Finland across 12 indicators
scale runs from 0 to 120 Somalia scored
the highest at 114 point 9 and Finland
ranked the lowest so this is the average
failed state index for for all countries
in Africa hovering around 90 the lowest
degree of the provision of social order
of any continent countries with armed
conflicts so we see Africa not much
worse than Asia but still we're talking
about we're talking about from
especially in the late 1990s we're
talking about 30 percent of the
countries in Africa having a civil war
civil war is defined as militias
fighting fighting the army of the state
in which at least a thousand people are
killed
here's countries that was armed conflict
that's 25 deaths or more the next one
I'm sorry this one of those countries in
civil war and this is this is countries
with civil war and we're talking about
30 percent of the countries in in civil
war civil war duration this is an
interesting slide Africa civil war
duration is not any longer than the
average of the rest of the world what's
interesting about this slide for
students of civil war is that a
professor at Rutgers Roy lickle either
noticed about 15 or 20 years ago that
the average length of a civil war is
about ten years average length of an
interstate war is about three years and
civil wars tend to tend to be much more
difficult to end a couple of students in
statuses generation Barbara Walters try
to figure out why that was the case in
terms of unable inability of the two
sides to know whose army would actually
provide order and whereas in interstate
war the two armies Google back to their
capitals in the intrastate war where
does the losing army go and the losing
army doesn't want to disappear and
therefore it's much more difficult to
assure them that they will be integrated
in a new society anyway
Africa has not done worse in terms of
length of civil war and in terms of
battle deaths this doesn't decay this
doesn't count for say Rwanda genocide in
1994 this is for civil wars and not
massacres Africa has not performed worse
so the civil wars don't last any longer
and the battle deaths aren't much higher
but in terms of coup frequency
the numbers of Coos in Africa are
extraordinary although you see a big
decline in the Americas and in Asia
you're beginning to see a decline in
Africa but still the number of coos and
the kinds of coos Africa gets which I'll
be describing in an excellent lecture
are quite different
so social order is summary controlling
for GDP per capita is not more
susceptible to civil war on sets and
other continents second Africa's civil
wars are sure the duration and have few
babel fewer battle deaths than civil
wars in other continents but for much of
Africa's contemporary history
alternation and power has been through
coos I can adjust that slightly based
upon last two days of history but
Africa's states remain this is the state
fragility index remain far more fragile
and less able to govern than States and
other continents
the third outcome variable regime type
in which democracy is one value back to
kwame nkrumah here kwame nkrumah is
voting in the first independent election
in Ghana and a few years later he's no
longer president he's no longer
president and kuma or kind of datin kuma
or Kwame
he's Redeemer
that's next lecture but but when we see
the and kwame nkrumah giving up to a
coup d'etat it was the sense of a cold
awakening a cold awakening for
Africanist and David after wrote a
brilliant essay describing that moment
in a journal called Daedalus so polity
has index of democracy that goes from
minus 10 to +10 minus 10 is Saudi Arabia
or or today North Korea the highest
levels of autocracy plus 10 is Sweden
Canada and they even put us there
because they're nice to us so that this
score minus 5 this goes up to 10 minus 5
represents an autocracy which is not
completely rapacious what's interesting
and I'm to get to this later is that
it's generally felt that if you're in
the realm from minus 5 to +5 we call
this anak recei that is neither
democracy nor autocracy and it turns out
that these anak receives are much more
susceptible to breakdown they're not
rapacious enough to keep people down and
they're not nice enough to keep people
happy
something like that but between minus 5
and plus 5 when you put anak recei on
the right-hand side of an estimation of
a civil war probability of a civil war
on set
anak recei turns out to be highly
predictive and africa as you'll see has
persisted between minus 5 and plus 5 for
most countries for most countries on the
continent
the polity scores over time in
sub-saharan Africa as you can see these
are the number of cases in this line
represents the average for each year and
it's moved from 1960 to about from about
minus 4 now to about zero or just a
little bit above zero so there has been
a slow movement towards democracy but
you couldn't actually call it a wave of
a fourth wave of democracy or some wave
of democracy there's been some
improvements and lots of setbacks
I hope tomorrow's I mean the other
yesterday's election will change this
blue line with this blue line is
representing from all these some of all
these other light lines is the vote
chair of the leading opposition party
and what we basically see is a vote
chair around 25% which means the winning
party is getting 65 is that right is
getting a 75% of the vote and scholars
like Leo Arreola at Berkeley have
studied the question why why can't
opposition parties consolidate why can't
they consolidate in order to actually
provide real challenges to incumbents
and one of his answers is that because
the there will be say four or five or
six different challengers to an
incumbent who is who we they can agree
upon to become their leader if if you
watch the if you watch the Israeli
election the the opposition had that the
opposition had that problem the first
they said they were going to share
leadership first for two years and then
the other one second two years but lapiz
got such bad rankings from from the
populace they they changed and said okay
it'll just be just be one person who
would challenge Netanyahu how do you get
a consolidated consolidated opposition
and what's interesting about the
Nigerian election a few guys have been
following it is the key to one of the
keys to boo Harry's victory is that he
was able to buy off buy off bring into
the coalition the governor of the state
neighboring Goodluck Jonathan's in River
State he was able to get that guy to
join in breaking into the core zone of
the incumbent
and and the guys in River were willing
to say get a deal from
Buhari that they that they would go that
they would work in the opposition and I
believe the final vote was sort of I
didn't see the exact thing but sort of
like 48 percent for the for the loser
but the loser happened to be the
incumbent so that was a big change the
big problem of African democracy you can
see from this is opposition's have not
been able to consolidate largely because
of inability to agree upon who amongst
the potential opponents of the incumbent
would become leader if the incumbent is
defeated so lack of consolidated or lack
of consolidated opposition is one
explanation for one explanation for
Africa's failure to have full
democracies
political rights here you can say for
many of the continents the what's called
the Seri measure toxic this percentage
of countries that score the worst
possible score on this measure of
disappearances extrajudicial killings
torture and political imprisonment and
what we see is that if we look say here
Asia in terms of disappearances in terms
of extrajudicial killings in terms of
torture and in political imprisonment
Asia takes the cake
but you can see that Africa is no small
potatoes in in perpetrating
disappearances extrajudicial killings
torture let's say 55 percent of the
African countries in 2010 had the lowest
score possible on use of torture and in
30 38 percent of the cases the worst
coding for political imprisonment
political rights are also are also not
the worst in the world but not something
that we should be happy about so if
anything this lecture is designed to
illustrate the problematic Africa is in
terms of development the last frontier
since independence Africa's progress has
been halting at best
while not demonstrable more violent than
other developing regions newly
independent African governments have not
provided social order and many states
too many states have failed to provide
any order second on all human
development indicators from wealth to
human capital to Health African states
have fallen behind developing countries
another continents and third the
democratic governance in Africa has
often failed and only rarely has it
consolidated it is understanding this
gap and what sustains
that's the focus of the next two
lectures yeah what was this very
illuminating
if the person has you predicted it would
be but you want that you didn't talk
about at all this tomography and the
demographic transition might account for
some of this but would you just talk
about that somehow you see that so the
the third lecture has what political
scientists or economists would call
exogenous factors factors which weren't
caused by the very problems that we're
looking at scientist factors that
explain the these outcomes and probably
the the first one I'll be talking about
is the one that was really identified by
Yale PhD Jeffery herbes on on the issue
of demography and the interesting thing
about herps insight was that the special
demography of Africa in which there are
pockets of population very very far away
from other pockets and the costs for
either the colonial leaders or for the
independence leaders to bring order
requires them to have linkages across
vast empty spaces and the returns to
bringing order to the to the deep
peripheries of their country are very
low and often negative and they abandon
them so the demographic patterns in in
africa herps argues have hindered the
consolidation of order and also
motivated you can call them political
entrepreneurs in the peripheries to
challenge state authority so i'm going
to show you a graph based upon a recent
dissertation
showing the greater difficulty it is for
the state to reach a peripheral area the
more likely that group is going to be in
rebellion that's number one and number
two this is my third lecture you won't
have to come that and the other one is
latitude latitude for reasons nobody
understands not only predicts varieties
of species but it also predicts
varieties of languages and if you do any
kind of statistical estimation about the
what we will call ethnic linguistic
fractionalization that is their
likelihood of two people are brought
together in the country they'll speak
the same language if you know speak a
different language if you look at at the
linguistic fractionalization that is a
big predictor of failure to provide
public goods and latitude connects to
high levels at neck fractionalization
which connects to low levels of public
goods so the democrat and of course the
demography of after africa wasn't caused
by the corruption in nigeria it was
independent of the corruption in nigeria
but you could say the that the the the
standard demographic situation of
african states is has been has been a
tremendous burden that not only the
colonial states but the independent
states had had to face and one more
point on this is that if you look at
countries which herps would call having
favorable geographies many of these bad
outcomes are not observed at the same
rate
presentation so when did your
presentation leaves us feeling too
depressed and so clearly sub-saharan
alphabet has not done well in terms of
economic development since independence
and clearly also there is a state
problem but controlling three levels of
economic development I don't know that
we need to think about Africa as a
political ladder or as a compliment
actually I do point out once we control
for GDP per capita actually we knew we
have you know come between expect maybe
even less the people had battle deaths
and things like that once we control for
GDP per capita actually ivan is doing
better than expected in terms of
democracy and so just to me that you
know and Jean Francois Payard said what
is Africa given us the art of living
without a state and so you know a lot of
people who do these DVDs they go in
after conflict and are surprised that
actually there's a quite high levels of
social cohesion in these villages and so
you know granted yes so the solution to
the steepness problem the solution did
you in your heart these are not easy
problems but so many of the other things
that we were to control for that I could
actually may be doing better than
expected and so it's not like we have to
solve them all necessarily independently
see the influence of James C Scott and
this maybe maybe be best if we didn't
have any states one second the control
the control for GDP the problem with
that is that if you look at 1960 they
had the same GDP per capita in education
in Africa which doesn't compare to
education and investment education in
South Korea you can't control for GDP
per capita
because we it starts off with store five
starts off the same rate that's why I
started off at at T zero equals the time
of independence yes it's true that
controlling for GDP per capita
explains a lot of the variants but then
we have to explain why the GG boo boo
cat the other point I would make is the
amazing thing
the amazing thing that's that's you
could say Scott Ian about your comment
is that where is the where is the best
cell phone service in all of Africa does
anyone know Somalia it's fantastic and
you can buy anything you want it's like
47th Street camera in New York and 50
years ago you can buy anything you want
it's the best price in the world all you
have to do is be able to go to the
markets either easily in Kenya which are
run by the Somalis or in South southern
Somalia so in the sense there are
returns to to non-state this but I would
still contend I would still contend that
if you're living wanting to live a
middle-class life in Mogadishu the fact
that you can buy get great cell phone
service but the fact that you have to
offer they have to employ a small army
to get your kid to school it would be
nice if that social order were provided
for free yeah I was wondering and
whether it makes sense for you to
conduct allow the kind of thought
experiment that is to go back to this
the time of independence in the sixties
when those states got started and think
how you saw things at the time and
whether you could identify in retrospect
outliers that these countries you
thought at the time would do well ended
up doing badly living bubbles and the
opposite states that you thought started
on a very bad food but ended up doing
much better as a way to sort of
stimulate the thinking in the discussion
yeah again again maybe I should have
given my third lecture first that there
was a great wager in in Africa when when
Kwame Nkrumah visited what the country
that became cote ivoire and hoofed wave
1yi was about to become the first
president of Cote d'Ivoire and
and and in his in his introduction to
president and kuma that hoof way said
this is gonna be a great wager you're
betting on socialism and you think that
the the Soviet and the other experiences
are relevant to Africa and all those
economic ideas that brought rapid growth
to the yeast is going to work for Africa
we think the opposite and let's in
respect look ten years down the line of
who did who's going to do better and
they shook hands on that and the data
will be on the slide and in lecture
three where Cote d'Ivoire just far
surpasses Ghana and it is true that the
dominant economic policies at the time
of African independence import
substitution industrialization for one
pushed by international pushed by great
international economists like Raul
Pradesh turned out to be an intolerable
disaster and those who ignore that most
clearly some who flake but most clearly
the guys who ran Botswana brought
tremendous growth and those of us who
thought that the socialist experience
was where rapid growth would come
predicted disaster for Botswana when
exactly the opposite occurred that's the
other half of lecture three
I won't make you have any segment
assigned next up with subsequent
lectures or complicity of the West
completion as a way speaking of the
terrible problems general throughout all
the decades I'm you know advance that no
other continent has been subjected to
the catabolism and mystic you know
Africa civilization and one of the
things you find in in Africa is that
pretty much everyone in the West every
politic has a pet project that they are
running in Africa and sometimes those
end up feeling very bad I'll give you a
very practical example for my
experiences I was once a policy analyst
in the Office of the President and was
in the position I am quite hot by any
Commission's anything else come back to
say early on to work on my the president
so while I was while I was in there as a
policy analyst I kind of oversaw the
transition the eventually there was a
guy who's a UNDP rep at the time called
Vito and John and he was hell-bent for
regime change
he wanted to see a transfer of power
from one party to the other party
because he believed that the incumbent
party was corrupt and inefficient and
all of these reasons he was David and he
was hell-bent on pretty much fallout of
a better way of putting the manipulating
the electrons and look where that got
CLL to there look at look at the
president are you putting in each office
look at the Ebola crisis look at the
recent constitutional violation of
removing the vice-president and we have
function another one very much
so pretty much I feel bad I hope and I
hope your lecture will have a very
wounded you know if you can measure of
complicity of the West in terms of a
mystic to support towards Africans that
we can pretty much go up on ourselves we
are pretty much job if it today this is
some time ago early today we are
considered the lowest of the low we can
make decisions for ourselves every
position has to be incidental for
Africans and Nigeria but pretty lucky
there was a lucky break and some
something else that people I don't know
maybe recognizing going forward or the
feature of the scores and IV separate
recognize is the character of good luck
Jamaica the guy who basically owns it
wasn't even holding on to power how do
you begin Rodin's power will have
eternal a different story today so I
really hope you have been variable for
the complicity of the West Africans and
I wish I did that
measuring paternalism is not something
that I've been able to think through but
I will I will have one small discussion
where we're political scientists Jim
Breeland at at Georgetown and Randy
stone at at at Rochester have tried to
ask the question have tried have asked
the question what is the degree to which
African leaders get rewarded for kissing
the behinds of the West so I'll give you
one piece of data on this to give you a
sense of what the findings look like
after 1982 the African Development Bank
which had previous to 8 1982
basically funded itself realized it
needed more funding and began accepting
funding from from the OECD and why do we
see about the funding decisions
so what Jim Breeland does is looks at
the countries from Africa which are on
security council and it turns out that
the ones on the Security Council get a
higher percentage of the funding then
then they would have gotten based on
other objective criteria which I'll be
describing in the third lecture so in
other words that that that aid has come
in the sense as a reward for voting with
the west and acting like the West rather
than on presenting programs which would
bring the best development under the
george w bush government with this
millennial challenge fund they try to
overcome that but have but the program
has not been able to operate in a way -
for countries to meet their standards
well enough to disperse the money they
thought they were going to disburse so
we have evidence that African states get
rewarded not for good performance
economically at least on the margin but
for voting for for OECD or Western
interests so so that's that's one way to
give some kind of support support to
your proposition to say they get treated
they get treated paternalistically what
you would have to show is that the South
Koreans or the Taiwanese or this the
other a the Indians got treated less
paternalistically and that would be hard
to figure out the measure of
inter-continental paternalistic feelings
but but it may be the case
so I'm from Salomon tonight and Flemmi
that grin off because I'm absolutely
only work 21 of the debt one of the
discourses I've heard when he goes to
this two main percentage that I've heard
growing up he's in South Africa on the
one hand things are horrible nothing's
changed its independence well what
evident even become independent but
that's another story altogether this
back it's horrible all dying with civil
war etc and so forth the other time the
other the other story that I've been
into yes in Luke chapter 16 was an
Africa rising which is we have some of
the fastest-growing economies in the
world we have an increasing number of
billionaires we have an increasing
number of resources being exploited the
you know so on and so forth but
something that I bet a memory that will
always stay with me was when I went to
South was and when I went to K times in
South Africa and I looked over a part of
an atomic bridge looking overlooking the
the slum kynesha and there was something
painted on the side of the pre
first-rate people shall share in the
wealth of the nation which was a lying
that country with South African
Constitution when Nelson under they
finally on for tonight's winters the
population and something that I think is
is an interesting question is to what
extent does income inequality
destroy the Infinity start the ability
of African states to read to read in
creepy people capita across across the
board because it's used to me that this
used to be pockets of extraordinary
wealth and then vast quantities of
people who have no money at all living
as you say on invested $2 a day so how
do you think if at all if it hasn't
effect what kind of effects GCU have you
so I have to go back
I hadn't been in Africa for many years
and there was an international
conference in Cape Town two years ago
and after which most of my colleagues
went off on wine tours but we guys we
guys who live near Napa don't care about
wine tours so I hired a young man from
University of Western Cape and I became
a border and a small in a small shanty
in Khayelitsha and lived there for a
week and this
well it was it was almost a nice shack
with running wire and some electricity
and all and this woman who ran this
bed-and-breakfast her mother was subject
to group areas act and forced out of her
Cape Town neighborhood into Khayelitsha
and so she was second generation and
second generation ANC born and bred and
every night listening to her and her
friends talk about nothing being done in
Khayelitsha that people would take the
these government supplied outhouses and
throw them in the street and burn them
to show their anger and and the my
hostess will call her said that the
antsy folk here know exactly where the
drug drug gangs are why we can't get any
public goods they know exactly and they
don't do anything because they know that
I can't vote other than the ANC but
that's the last time I'm building for
ANC it's the Democratic Party for me
Democratic Democratic Alliance and so in
Part III I think South Africa is one of
the greatest success stories in the
world nobody predicted to be a
transition to this democracy they have
no one that I know predicted that this
would occur this way there are levels of
violence which are unimaginable to
people living in La Jolla or to in Palo
Alto
but still it's a well-ordered society I
was told by everyone don't take the
train into Cape Town where all the
workers are going it's an hour and
fifteen minutes by train in the morning
because they run the whole service
economy in Cape Town it's more orderly
than anything I've seen in Chicago
people are sitting everything in
newspapers well-dressed you know
completely peaceful and the most
important thing in the Khayelitsha
supermarket they went to there were ATMs
out there I can't imagine this in
Nigeria and you go up to the ATM to put
in your code and the next person waiting
behind you was like
and feet behind you giving you space you
can't imagine that in Nigeria why am I
saying this I'm saying this because I
think that the future the future of
South Africa depends not so much on
these poor people who are unable to act
but on the ability of an insurgent group
within the ANC to split it I don't think
the Democratic Alliance has the history
correct history to challenge the NCA but
a breakup of the ANC would be the best
thing that could happen for the poor it
would force the ANC into providing
services and providing basic services
providing decent housing and electricity
for the poor which now it doesn't have
to worry about they're very close to
that and I think Zuma is helping a great
deal in working towards the breakup of
the ANC and and and that would be a
historic moment it's happened in India
with a breakup of Congress so it's not
so much the people who are poor are
unable to act I think they're stuck to
their historical memories of the ANC
which is preventing an opposition which
can actually compete with services
that's a kind of a larger political view
played against also another continental
level but I also wonder the degree to
which the informal economy features
within these statistics because we know
in some places that's the only kinds of
economic activity that exists whether or
not it's making it into service nation
state level figures of GDP is another
question I think there's all kinds of
economic activity that isn't getting
incorporated in these kinds of figures
they can also help answer some bigger
questions we have about problematically
universal idea of development in these
kinds of places the idea that simply
living I know
I work in Uganda I worked there for a
number of years now seven or so and just
because living on $2 a day isn't
necessarily a poverty level situation if
you own your own land you grow your own
food and really all you need to do is
spend your money it on sugar or paraffin
or something like that but in the
absence of things like land on which you
can make and produce the stuff of life
is quite different you know one of the
one of the biggest challenges to the use
of GDP per capita Bell prize-winning
Indian economist a case end and he was
behind the development of an alternative
called the Human Development Index which
looks at a whole range of outcomes
besides besides money that counted in in
national accounts and I've used HDI
in in some of my work that would be
presented in the second lecture and what
you'll see basically is some of the same
distressing same distressing outcomes
now it is true that poor people on $2 a
day can can survive if they have a small
shaunb a small farm there's no doubt
about that but I think the aspirations
of people throughout the continent and
throughout the world is to be able to to
enjoy the health the probability that
that mother's will survive the
probability that the kids the kids will
survive the probability that they can
get an education so that they can
compete for jobs in the international
market that these are what's lacking
it's not that they can't survive it's I
can't achieve what their their their
broader goals would want them to achieve
thanks very much for the talk I wanted
to ask about a little bit about the
first 50 and 60 years of the 20s
sorry by way of understanding how you
now think about this celebratory moment
that you started the presentation with
this sort of moment of Independence
which we often take to be the start of
state formation and I think implicit in
that celebration is the idea that the
colonial project was impeding growth and
state consolidation and that was
stepping out of the way so I'm wondering
how do what do we make of that that
celebratory moment now and we're looking
back with all these current problems is
it in fact should we think of it as kind
of point zero the start of state
formation or is it possible that this
wasn't so much as a rupture and maybe
were artificially starting our databases
there if we can't get data that much
earlier but actually just a new phase
and an ongoing struggle to consolidate
state power that maybe the European
would throw all this less a big triumph
than just another in a series of failed
rulers who didn't manage to consolidate
the state and develop the economy I
guess I'm just thinking of some people
from North Africa to tell me ah we got
independence and the new people are no
better than the old ones they're the
same so for their identity is different
yeah it reminds me when I was spending
Eden in the town called Brava
and a bunch of Somali they were then in
Brava they speak they speak Swahili
there or branch of Swahili this couple
of a sky we're taking this woman into a
prison and she said you can't do this
where are the Italians so but more
seriously there's a large literature but
you're part of on that era and and
what's interesting if you read say
proffered Young's book on the African
colonial state it's it it's a wonderful
book as Crawford Young is one of the
great scholars of African politics but
there are actually no propositions in it
that says that because of X in the
colonial state we have why today or
because of this variation in
in the colonial state we have this
variation on some outcome and so what
I've done in preparation for this
lecture series is to try to extract from
Crawford Young's work some propositions
of that sort to see to ask the questions
what were the effects of the colonial
era it's a short it's a short era we're
talking about 1884 to 1957 but just to
give you a kind of foreshadowing of this
though you know they were work of the
historian Richard Reid it's really a
remarkable book what it shows is that in
the mid 19th century the military
technology in Africa is catching up to
the rest of the world is a military
revolution but where is the military
power coming from not from the
traditional leadership but from
insurgent state builders and these
insurgent state builders are in a sense
creating what looks like new state forms
based on merit systems because they were
looking for the best soldiers importing
the best the best material and what do
the colonists do they come in and say oh
we're gonna rule through the traditional
leaders by ruling through the
traditional leaders in language I've
used before they gave authority that is
their military might to people who had
legitimacy that this is traditional
leaders and were able to recreate an
order which they thought was State
Building meanwhile meanwhile undermining
the real state building that was
happening with the military revolution
in Africa that's one thing that the
colonial project did not the only one
but that's the beginning of a
proposition to say where the where the
real military sort of revolution was
occurring are there places where they
got the power and the state and the
anything different happen and that's the
sort of the observable implication
of reeds work which I haven't done yet
but at least I got a proposition either
that literature status has a two-finger
more politically correct direction would
be to argue that as Jeffrey herb said
perhaps the norm against changing
borders and fighting interstate Wars has
been bad for Africa that's point number
two in lecture three the international
norm of no changing borders that that
kennethj a way that Berkeley has argued
in the 1960s he said that if it weren't
for the OAU bargain of no changing
boilers rwanda would Rwanda would be one
of the great states Rwanda was the
pressure of of
Africa and would be orderly ruling over
Kiva province and we wouldn't have what
we have today but that's third lecture
about democracy being one of the
measures of success it might not be the
case that democracy is an omen regime
was come for the development as we see
in China also the way South Africa from
South Korea which did us wrong return
arranged and so on so and your audience
about the or missed an election I mean
what are your thoughts about
alternatives to democracy why would the
Marcos II have to be one of these
measures and I would say going back to
how I answered or quickly added on to
studies that Kagame is building no
democracy but he's building a very well
ordered state whether you like it or not
and and that it's exactly what happened
in Taiwan exactly what happened in South
Korea you had basically people were
Singapore basically people who created
order and once order was created then
you could think about the new middle
class wanting some of the
the political rights that for civil
society yes I didn't want to say that
democracy was a necessary or even an
important element towards development I
did want to say four three dependent
variables about which we care democracy
regime type freedom development and
order that that all the things being
equal people would prefer prefer to live
under democracy for a variety of reasons
and that but if they were mmm we know
that from every survey we run from afro
barometer to to Asian survey to to world
value survey when you ask random
selected people around the world what
what what type of government they would
want that's what they tell you they want
more freedom rather than less well
there's a great book by Frederick Shafer
on this and I'm enseña Gao of when when
the Senegalese say democracy adieu they
mean the same thing that we mean and not
quite but the Venn diagram is a good
deal of overlap but Schafer's book is
fabulous on that very question the only
one who's done serious John Austin type
ordinary language analysis
the nation-state as the unit of analysis
but look across other regions of
influence areas of cultural coherence
specifically linguistic continuity and
you would would the continent look
uniformly this one as it does and I know
that for as an Egyptian working in Sudan
that if you thought of so then as
different regions of in of influence in
terms of Suki groups or linguistic
groups or ethnic tribal groups that
actually the story is quite different
from one part of it to the next so I'm
wondering if you would think that it's
possible to think in Africa yeah I think
that's a excellent point and there are a
number of scholars who looked at James
Ferguson for one who has done this and
you might even say will Reno has done
this when he calls the shadow States and
looking at networks which actually
provide order rather than than capitals
that report to the United Nations and
that and that what you see is you could
call this the real Africa that is the
Africa in which in which basic services
are provided in which informal forms of
Taxation in which that there are no such
things as presidents and prime ministers
and ministries ministers of Education
but there is our Lebanese arms merchants
and then and then some local Chiefs and
then a few World Bank operatives all
working in a certain region trying to
bring that sort of network to get some
growth now you're seeing a lot of that
around around Chinese investments
throughout Africa which is the biggest
growth area in Africa today in which you
have the Chinese couldn't care less
about what happens in the capital city
they care about what happens in there so
land acquisition
they're industrial for hmm yes and that
but the ultimately I think in the world
we now live in that this has to a
grenade up to the nation-state level if
in fact the nation-state which has the
capacity to in the sense with impunity
roll over any of those projects it has
the capacity to in the sense send the
Chinese back it has the capacity to tax
tax these these micro environments in
ways that can destroy them or help them
grow and in the world we now live in the
ability of the nation-state where their
capital city to get international
resources to act in ways which are both
challenging or helpful to those micro
environments still makes in that the
nation-state relevant but maybe a whole
lot less relevant that I've been
portraying in this first lecture all
given how diverse is it really much
value studying development in Africa
using Africa's units opposed to the
individual nation-states within it
because as you mentioned some success
stories
is it bad it doesn't do justice to the
true signaler fans in the continent
could compare all of them just coming
together to study do this one yeah it's
an interesting question you asked before
I started this when festersen badness
invited me to give lectures and I said I
couldn't give lectures well he asked me
but I'm gonna teach a new course in
African politics which I haven't taught
in a generation maybe I can consolidate
them I looked at I looked at maybe 15 or
20 syllabi on African politics given
around the country in the last 15 or 20
years and they all had a common theme to
say we want you to appreciate how
diverse Africa is and how much variance
there is throughout the continent and
you have Assefa --less systems and you
have hierarchical systems you have
nomads and you have farmers you have
places that have experience in direct
versus places of experience direct rule
and and let's get you an appreciation
for the tremendous variety and so this
lecture series was a sense a counter to
that to say appreciating the diversity
is okay but there are some broad
patterns here that that that nearly all
African states have not have not
achieved the goals of the first
generation of charismatic leaders nor
the the john f kennedy's or others who
thought that freedom freedom would yield
a better life for the peoples of the
country and and like it or not the
problem the problem is generic and even
the great success stories like botswana
are nowhere close in terms of gdp per
capita is the tigers of asia so yes
there are success stories but the the
general the the general pattern the
variance is not that great
yeah I know these are interdisciplinary
lectures you're trying to avoid
technical terms for now but um I didn't
want to ask a question about
coordination I mean so a lot of your
work has been in the has used Prima
coordination problems which you know for
people who don't know is where
essentially where people would have
would benefit greatly from settling on
doing the same thing or adopting some
standard or practice but have trouble
settling on what that would be where
there's the common language or common
currency of the same government and a
lot of the things you've talked about
can be you know seen in terms of
coordination problems so in civil wars
people would benefit from picking the
strongest army and and plumping for that
but they don't know which that is you in
any coordinating on opposition leaders
is obviously that sort of problem they
benefit from coordinating on the same
one but they can't sit on you that is
language has change of borders in some
ways can be seen as a symbol would you
say I mean this may be anticipating a
later lecture but when you say that that
provides you know a fairly good
framework for you for unifying some of
these explanations and is so maybe a
meta question you know is is it hard to
get people to think about coordination
when maybe james-scott lights are used
to thinking about that about the
downside of bigness serves people doing
the same thing they think those Rebels
then it's hard to it's right to you know
to make people appreciate the virtues of
sort of settling on doing the same thing
as everybody else and you know and
compromising and something bigger than
your preferred unit or your preferred
practice yeah that's really an
invitation to talk about myself
yeah so in in this second lecture I'm
presenting new data on on this
coordination issue on language I've
written on good a good deal on the I
called I called one of the essays the
tower of the Tower of Babel is a
coordination game in which everyone
wants to have an indigenous language to
be the official language of the state
but they can't agree on which one so to
use the language of a lemurs ruby they
picked the one in which no one speaks or
is no one's indigenous language
that and that but no one no one had
really estimated no one had really
estimated the cost of use of the
colonial languages for education and and
the scholar who just got his PhD in
Pompeo five in in Barcelona who was
originally from Tamil Nadu came to me at
a conference and said I figured out how
to measure this and that the the cost
the the cost of relying on the European
languages in terms of development is is
so much greater than almost any other
variable we were able to put in as
causal for develop for human human
capital is the outcome variable for the
loss of human capital
yeah it's extraordinary and the way we
do this is create a measure we call
average distance of the average distance
to the to the official language of state
a DOL and every country has a figure for
a DOL measured by every single language
in the world
given this Summer Institute of
linguistics scale has an address and we
could say how far any language is from
any other language by Counting how far
the addresses like a Google map type
thing and then we say what's the
distance for each language group from
the official language and what's the
proportion of the population in that
language group and then summit and what
we find crossed nationally and within
Africa the higher levels of a DOL the
lower levels of GDP growth the lower
levels of human development and next the
lowest levels of educational attainment
an extraordinary outcome of the cost so
Africa not only comes out lowest of the
continent in terms of a DOL that is
having the highest a DOL but also within
Africa the country
that have better a deal a DOL scores do
much better developmentally and then the
question is how can they coordinate on
an outcome which would bring higher
levels of human capital you see this in
the coordination game as you pointed out
in the data I gave you on on the the
size of the second largest this the
second largest party in African
elections are on average 25 percent if
they could coordinate the chances of
democracy are much greater
so yes coordination failure linked
largely to e.l.f that is a degree to
which there's ethnic linguistic
fractionalization seems to be a major
issue differentiating African countries
from the rest of the world and why you
have different ILF scores is going to be
something I'll be discussing in the
second lecture pretty well in other
states then we had a few comments about
fixing keeping what is the same and I
wondered if the analysis might benefit
at all if instead of starting and
stating the date of Independence as a
zero times zero or greater than zero and
we instead lifted
and in terms recognizing that
independence wasn't a blank slate and
instead that could organism they lift
many barriers intact such as I'm
standing the leadership of coexistence
of how we divide resources and so in
looking at development look at how the
African nations were sent to make up was
very so it's a good question a number of
people who do stuff like I do make T 0 x
0 the first year of independence so for
India that's 19 what 47 for the 8 for
Indonesia about the same so you you use
the first year of independence and then
you and then you develop a scale of what
the real GDP per capita the first year
and then you ask what happens in the
first 10 years after independence and
from what I recall we don't get we don't
get results a whole lot different but
it's a worthy project because it's the
right way to think it's the right way to
think about intercontinental comparisons
yeah but one the after a very very
difficult period of what's called
structural adjustment to the 1980s it
brought it brought you to be for cap to
unimaginable low levels so the growth
levels we're seeing now are just high
because it's starting out for it's such
a terrible base so don't be fooled by
the percentages because she hasn't have
to think about how low it how low it
felt fell in the 1980s that's the that's
the nasty or the negative part of the
story that that now basically you can't
get you an African leader cannot get
money from World Bank or from IMF unless
they have in the ministry in the
Treasury they have someone who's been on
Wall Street
and you just can't
there was a interesting book on Latin
America's happened a while back called
the dollar doctor I think bye-bye
what's the name Paul name escapes me for
a moment that basically there was a
there was a bond raider in in in wall
street who in the early twentieth
century would go the Latin American
capitals and and and giving the word but
they had a serious economic they had a
wall streeter in the in the government
and and they they couldn't get
international capital unless this guy's
put a check mark there and and that's
basically it's and that's a good
basically a good thing so you basically
have really highly qualified people
including the the President of Liberia
who comes out of this is the same group
of world World Bank experts who come
back to Africa as either ministries of
ministers of Treasury or as presidents
so in the sense you're not getting the
the really crazy policies of I've been
discussed some next like tomorrow of of
currency currency control in which you
make imports virtually costless
destroying your whole agricultural
sector you now have currency policies
that that leaders can't do that and
still have access to international
capital so in other words we have we
have some rope or rap hooey oacd is some
rope around the necks of the financial
ministries that think they just can't
they just can't act in ways which
counter any kind of economic rationality
so there's been some change in that
regard
just to go with that I think then the
next most interesting question would be
well how do you see the relationship
between China and many states and in
Africa for example mostly because
China's B has been characterized I'm not
I'm gonna tell you sure this is true as
we characterize is offering
no-strings-attached aid where it's not
necessary that you need to get me where
Africa States can explain what they want
a challenge is you know some code that
coalescence and then trying to get near
this trade without necessarily
expectation but they need to copy a
Chinese system owner or a u.s. system or
a Western system whatever it may be how
do you think that that's changing the
dynamic when it comes to where capital
can be found that's one of the that's
one of the biggest questions for which I
have no answer but there's been a recent
paper it's not it's still in a working
paper that links these large mining and
land mining and international mining and
land direct investments in Africa
largely coming from China that's the
size of that on the right hand side of a
estimation and left hand side levels of
protests protests in the African
populations and it's pretty robust so in
the sense you could say that as a good
thing that these investments and there's
a recent book by Cathy Boone which I
recommend I don't know even know if it's
out yet but on how this is working
locally local Chiefs she not only argues
but demonstrates are able to use their
autonomy to make deals with Chinese and
other investors to give them wonderful
land and then the people who are in the
community who thought this was community
land see what's happening and a good
deal of this a glad this low-level
twenty five the last violence that we're
seeing in Africa in the past ten years
much higher than civil wars is coming
from communities going against their own
Chiefs this is what this paper is
picking up low levels of protest
and these protests I think will grow to
the extent to which these sweetheart
deals with mining and large agricultural
investments of who is giving them the
land with what with what rights and what
was what implications for the people who
thought they had rights